good morning or good afternoon everyone
depending on where the globe you are
thank you for joining us on this webinar
my name is Joann a spur project manager
for pluripotent stem cell culture and as
mentioned earlier with me today is our
scientist from research and development
we're in San Gennaro today we will talk
about further potent stem cell based
cell therapy
more specifically looking at how you can
support work in this area with a variety
of cell therapy systems or cts products
most recently and most notably CVS
essentially eight medium
I'm sure you are well aware that third
potent stem cells our PSCs hold
tremendous potential for cell therapy
with their ability to soften you and
differentiate into many cell types of
the body according to this reference
many researchers around the world
recognize that and are working to
realize that potential through various
clinical studies using IPS ES and
perhaps you are already involved in one
of these studies or perhaps you aspire
towards joining these ranks and in any
case I hope that today's presentation
will help you realize the potential of
PS es in therapy
for my section I will talk about cell
therapy some considerations introducing
reagents and how we can help I will
briefly introduce the give Co essential
8 media system and go on to describe how
CD s essentially medium is based on
essential 8 but it is more appropriate
for cell therapy
I will then introduce and assemble the
compatible products in a workflow that
gives you the best support for your PSC
based cell therapies and just a quick
note in her section Lauren will show you
the data relevant to items number 3 and
4
with that out of the way my first point
is the single most important point that
I would like you to remember from this
talk when you think of cell therapy
reagents are no longer just reagents
when you're doing clinical research or
even when you're doing translational
work planning out what will eventually
be used in clinical research and Beyond
you have to think about your agents in
terms of how they would touch or
influence a therapeutic product as such
in a cell therapy mindset reagents
become ancillary materials how are they
different ancillary materials are
materials used in the manufacturing
process but are not intended to remain
in the final product and this includes
things like Culture Media although
they're not present in the final product
they are essentially your raw materials
in fact that's how ancillary materials
are referred to in Europe so all the
things you think about when it comes to
raw materials you do have to consider
here is it safe enough is it pure enough
it matters because materials used during
processing could influence the
performance of a final product it also
matters because it's possible that some
of this material could still end up in
the finished product even if you don't
need for it to
because ancillary materials are
to go to the quality of performance of
the performance of cell therapies there
are many direct and indirect regulatory
guidance 'as on the choice or use of
ancillary materials and here you just
see the main regulatory guidance
documents across the different regions
we are not going to go through each of
them but the point here is that reagents
in cell therapy do need to be reviewed
with different lenses than in basic
research they are regulatory lenses and
it may be slightly different lens even
depending on your strategy for example
where do you intend on developing or
commercializing a therapy
so the materials you use are
as reagents raw materials ancillary
materials with that in mind what do you
consider when choosing what to use first
and foremost of course you want a high
quality product that performs well next
because this is a raw material used to
generate therapies of course you wanted
to perform consistently next thinking
about a raw material more practically
you want to make sure that you have a
stable reliable supply that supports the
continuity of your work not only that
but also you want to make sure that your
supplier is able to accommodate your
increased need for that material once
you scale up for clinical trials and
Beyond and next as an ancillary
ancillary material that touches the
cells and eventually become a therapy
you want it to be as safe as it can
possibly be and very much related to
that you want it to comply with the
relevant regulations next and this is
not something that we've touched on yet
but you want to make sure that you
actually have rights to use the material
for commercial purposes and not all
products grant that and yet that is most
likely what you will need if you were to
bring your PSC work to the clinic and
finally if you're not using the exact
same reagent from start of development
to the end then you should consider our
agent or a set of reagents that give you
a clear path from bench to the clinic
and we'll talk about that a little bit
more later but clearly there is a lot to
think about when choosing ancillary
materials and many of these
considerations are not as simple as we'd
like them to be as you saw with just the
variety of regulations to consider and
moreover at the translational stage many
of these might feel like distant
concerns and it would be tempting to
really just you know put off thinking
about them at all however the earlier
you think about it the better because
you can choose the right reagent during
development and have a smooth back to
the clinic in the alternative non ideal
scenario you might develop the therapy
with one reagent and prepare for a
regulatory filing years after to find
that's the supplier can accommodate your
increased volume or you don't have
commercial rights or there are
regulatory concerns with your choice
maybe formulation is not appropriate for
cell therapy or the QC testing is
lacking or documentation is racking in
any case you'd have to account for the
extra effort and cost either rectifying
the issues with the current reagent if
that's even possible or switching to a
more suitable reagent and all the
redevelopment and comparability studies
that that might entail again not the
ideal situation but the good news here
is that we can help you with a number of
the considerations upfront
on the first point we have over 30 years
of experience manufacturing products
under cGMP our current good
manufacturing practices this is true
across multiple manufacturing sites and
across a wide variety of products
including most of our research use only
or ru o media along with our cell
therapy systems or cts products what
that means is that our manufacturing
sites are registered with the FDA and
are certified to certain ISO standards
the rigorous practices we adhere to at
these sites ensure the consistency
reliability and high quality of a wide
variety of PSC workflow reagents I'd
like to point out as an example I'll
give Co PSC culture media whether our UO
or cts our GMP manufactured
on the second point the same along
history experienced in that scale across
multiple sites enables us to provide you
with reliable supply and to continue
supporting you even as you scale
yourself and scale up your own
operations
now again up to this point since this
has to do with our company and our sites
in general this is true for both are you
oncbs products as we continue down the
list of how we can help you you'll start
to see more of the differences between
our UO and CTS products and why CTS
products provide the best support for
cell therapy needs
we'll start with safety
CTS products are specifically intended
for cell therapy and the such undergo
extensive safety testing at UC and all
set safety testing as well as raw
material information pertinent to safety
can be found in our certificate of
analysis and certificate of origin
next regulatory compliance we have
experienced technical quality and
regulatory teams to help us understand
the direct and indirect regulations as I
mentioned earlier they help us design
our CTS products so that we can minimize
regulatory risks and aim to satisfy our
regulatory requirements they also
collect and curate regulatory and
traceability information that can be
very challenging to do and then they
funnel this information into a more
readily available set of documents such
as our certificate of origin and often
also drug master files to facilitate
your regulatory filings finally the same
experts become resources that do provide
CGS customers with with support to avoid
pitfalls in their path to the clinic
next commercial use rights we provide
guidance and support for the commercial
use of CD s products in fact CD s
products typically carry the intended
Restatement for research use or
manufacturing of cell gene or tissue
based products
you
finally we have seamless transition we
understand that you may start your
research with quite sensibly a research
use product what we have RCDs products
that have the same or similar
formulations as our are you own products
except making the formulations Eno free
or animal origin free to reduce risk and
variability as such you can start with
the ru o product and know that when the
right time comes you can easily switch
to a CTS version
you
so these are different ways that we can
help and in fact we have helped quite a
bit
our products have been used in more than
a hundred seven genes gene therapy
clinical trials to date and beyond that
several of our products are used as
critical raw materials and
commercialized cell and gene therapy
manufacturing so you can trust us to be
your partner in bringing your own PSC
based therapy to the clinic
now let me switch gears here to
specifically talk about the essential
media system and how we can help you
here
essential eight medium is a feeder free
and zeno free PSC medium that uses the
Thompson Labs v8 formulation the medium
kit is comprised of a basal medium and a
supplement but it's named essential 8
because altogether it contains only 8
components that are critical for growing
PSCs this is the key reason that many
researchers have adopted essentially
medium 8 components means less sources
of variability compared to other media
that typically have a lot more
components 8 components also means that
it is more cost effective and therefore
more scalable than other more complex
media and again like all gecko PSC media
essential 8 is GMP manufacturing
for a clearer view of what I meant in
the previous slide the table on the Left
shows a comparison of a more traditional
medium and Kizer versus the eight
essential components in this media
system there's a clear difference in the
number of components of course and
stated below in the quote because it is
so simple it can be made in in a more
controlled way but one striking
difference in the formulation is the
presence of BSA in M keys or in the
absence of either BSA or HSA in
essential aid that's important because
BSA or HSA for that matter is animal
origin material and is a source of
variability as well as a potential
source of adventitious agents so
essential aid with the removal of BSA
and the recommended use of a defined
animal origin free substrate like that
Renekton provides a good foundation for
cell therapy grade medium and it's not
just because of the formulation itself
helps that we know that it works really
well we know it supports classic PSE
morphology normal karyotype hi PSE
marker expression and tri lineage
potential over many many passages it's
been tested in well over a hundred lines
and at this point has been cited in over
600 different publications for a variety
of PSC applications
for a while now we have offered
different versions variations or
combinations in the essential aid family
of products always of course trying to
provide the product that is right for
our customers no matter what it is that
they're doing
apart from essential 8 for PSC
maintenance and expansion there's
essentially flex with stabilized fgf2
activity for PSC maintenance with a
flexible feeding schedule or you can
combine either of those media with
provide to sell supplement for stressful
events like single sale packaging and
then there's a central six medium which
does not contain growth factors and can
serve as a great baseball medium for
differentiation or other PSC
applications
now expanding on a point I made earlier
being GMP manufacturers Ino free more
consistent and more cost-effective the
essential eight system has always lend
itself well to an eventual cell therapy
application but we knew that there were
opportunities to further tailor the
product for cell for cell therapy such
we now introduce the newest addition to
the essential aid family CTS essentially
eight medium this CTS version of
essentially medium was designed to meet
global health or the regulatory
requirements it reduces risks because it
is rigorously tested and is animal and
human origin free in fact right now it
is the only globally available animal
origin free PSC medium and then like the
rest of our CTS products it facilitates
regulatory filings with cGMP
manufacturing and regulatory
documentation finally it does enable a
seamless transition from the ru o
essentially medium because it uses the
same eight component formulation though
with animal origin for your AOF
components
going deeper into the differences in
terms of document date documentation PDF
essentially does have a drug master file
as I said it has a completely animal
origin free formulation and won't have
full traceability information and
documentation on the various components
of that formulation
as for QC it does undergo the same
functional testing using h9 es es over
three passages
though both have sterility testing CTS
essentially test really testing
according to USB it undergoes qPCR
mycoplasma testing and a stricter
endotoxin specs
say what is evident in all of these
differences is that we did perform our
regulatory risk assessment when CPS
essential aid was being designed we
looked at the original essentially
medium evaluated it against global
regulatory requirements and that is what
drove the improvements in the
formulation the documentation and the QC
testing to fit Socrates at the end of it
all we are able to provide a PSC medium
with e with a different infinity
statement that should again facilitate
your regulatory filing and that is for
research use or manufacturing Celgene or
tissue based products
obviously a PSE medium is not used in a
vacuum it fits into a complete workflow
often stretching from somatic cell
culture to reprogramming to banking
differentiation and characterization as
you can see here we have a complete and
robust offering across the ru Oh
essential 8 workflow PDS essential 8
being very similar has a list of
compatible products and the workflow
that basically mirrors this while
incorporating c.d.s products that would
better support cell therapy and then
altogether what you would see is a
seamless transition in the PSC work so
from our UO to CTS and we'll go through
this step by step
so if you're starting with fibroblasts
alter the standard fibroblast culture
medium contains FBS and we do have GMP
manufactured FBS as well as GMP
manufactured knockout serum replacement
as you might expect serum replacement is
more defined and this one is more
specifically used for PSC related
applications though more for feeder
dependent PSC culture differentiation
with further supplementation it can be
used for culturing fibroblasts pre
reprogramming of course for cell therapy
purposes we would recommend using CTS
knockout serum replacement excess which
is based on that widely cited ru o
product if the difference would be that
this is Zeno free and like other CTS
products it has more extensive testing
and has documentation to support
regulatory submissions
for the reprogramming step on the REO
side we have the site achoo and i PS 2.0
kit which has the highest success rate
among non integrating reprogramming
technologies for cell therapy we do have
a CBS version on CDF sighted student IPS
2.1 kit it's a really cool product it is
the first off-the-shelf reprogramming
system designed for clinical and
translational research what it does is
it replaces see make with L make for
weaker transformation activity it has no
BSA in the viral dilution buffer and
it's produced in a GMP certified
facility for consistency of the material
unlike the previous EDS product it
undergoes extensive testing and has the
documentation to support your regulatory
submission
in terms of PSC culture
yes essentially medium it is compatible
with give Co veteran actin which is the
defined matrix that the Thompson lab
designed for use with a central 8 system
it's also compatible with Gimpo lemon
and 5 to 1 which is also defined what
would be a more robust option and it's
great for challenging applications of
course were the best option for cell
therapy we do have CTS vit Remington and
that uses the same VPN and variant that
has been shown to support the attachment
and survival of PCs better than
wild-type that Renekton at this point
I'm sure you're spotting the trends it
has extensive testing and documentation
in terms of passages in the CTS
essentially system we primarily
recommend non-enzymatic passages with
our GMP manufactured Burstein solution
if you are at a stage where you need to
use a CTS product or want to do
single-cell passages you can use CTS
triple select enzyme which has the same
formulation as the REO product but has
extensive testing and regulatory
documentation if you do perform single
cell packaging with cts e8 just like
with essential 8 please do make sure to
use a Rock inhibitor we particularly
recommend our GMP manufactured provider
provide a cell supplement
for cryopreservation RZ no free and GNP
manufactured PSE cryopreservation kit
provides the best performance as it was
optimized for PCs for a great animal
origin free option with the usual CTS
benefits we do have CTS cyntha Fries
medium if you use cdsmp fries
we also recommend using revised SL
supplement post ball for optimal
recovery
now I won't go into the details of
differentiation since protocols and cell
types of interest vary widely but we do
have a wide variety of basal media
theorem replacement supplements and
growth factors under the CGS brand they
all have ru over ins and they all have
the same or similar formulation but
offer the extensive testing and
regulatory documentation that I've
mentioned with the others as well
so those products and recommendations
are summarized here and this is the CPS
essential eight workflow looking quickly
at the characterizations
pscs have traditionally used cellular
methods to look at PSC marker expression
fairly image potential after after the
reprogramming process after extended
culture number gene editing for example
these cellular methods are mostly Amina
staining but you can also do flow
cytometry but they're very qualitative
or semi-quantitative except when you go
into that flow cytometry level we do
have antibody kits that facilitate these
kinds of characterizations however
molecular methods enable more
comprehensive characterization in a more
standardized and scalable fashion these
are very important characteristics when
thinking about cell therapy therefore
along with the use of cts products if
you are going to cell therapy we
recommend characterization with the
pleura test si for per button see
confirmation the type of man HP SC
scorecard panels for travelin trailing
edge potential and the carry stat si for
assessing genomic stability in lieu of G
banding which you'll hear more about
when Lauren starts her section
so let me close my section with a
reminder of four key points first with
technical and regulatory expertise cgmp
compliant manufacturing sites in the
broad portfolio of cell therapy systems
products
Thermo Fisher Scientific is a trusted
partner in cell therapy second essential
a medium is a widely cited Feder free
PSC medium favored for its minimal and
defined
xeno free formulation drawing from that
we have our Third Point CGS essential
eight medium enables the seamless
transition to the clinic with an animal
origin free formulation extensive
testing and regulatory documentation and
lastly combining essential Aid and CVS
essential aid with the other products in
the workflow thermo Fisher offers a
complete and compatible set of our UO
and CTS products to support your PSC
workflow from bench to the clinic and
now I'm going to hand you over to Lauren
to go over the application data
okay in the second half of our
presentation I'd like to share some
application data for CTF d8
first we'll look at data comparing
research use and CTS e8 and all outline
how you can transition your cultures
between these two media next we'll look
at long-term PFC culture and then
finally we'll talk about scaling your
PFC s and also reprogramming with PTSD
eight
as Joanna mentioned earlier in the
presentation CTS CA contains the same a
components as research EC 88 but CTF t8
has all a little origin three versions
of these components so to be sure that
there are no differences in performance
between these two media we cultured pfcs
for a number of bursting quant passages
in both the research youths and in CGS
eh and then we looked at some typical
PFC characteristics and then images on
the Left panel of this slide you can see
representative PFC morphology for each
media the pscs here have the typical
attributes that you look for the cells
are tightly packed the colony edges are
smooth and they have high nucleus to
cytoplasm ratio in the right panel we
monitored from fluency over time for
PSCs cultured in both media as you can
see the growth curves are comparable for
research use and PTSD eight
so in terms of morphology and growth
kinetics both of these media performed
similarly
next let's look at maintenance support
potency for the two media for these
studies PFCs were cultured in both media
for 20 passages and then assayed for
pluripotency using two different methods
the left panel shows results of
quantitative ICC analysis
for both media there is a high there's
high expression of pluripotency markers
opt for nanog and socks too
the right panel shows the results of
pleurotus
which is an array based assay that
quantifies global gene expression it
includes markers found and pluripotent
and non flair put in cell types
in the plot PSP is cultured and research
use and cts see a cluster close to one
another and are within the Red Cloud
which is associated with pluripotent
cells
the final PFC characteristic that we
have compared between the media is trial
in each differentiation potential
for this study PSPs were cultured in
both media for 20 passages and then
embroid bodies were generated from the
cultures using essential six
the EVs were allowed to spontaneously
differentiate for 14 days and then we
collected them and asked they then using
the pac-man HP SD scorecard so a little
about scorecard
it's a Q PCR based assay that is based
on a reference panel of genes and it
includes markers for self renewal as
well as ectoderm musa german endoderm
the top left panel on the slide shows
scorecard results for undifferentiated
PSCs that were also collected at p 20
the pluses minuses here show that these
PFCs are able to self renew and are not
biased towards any of the lineages
there on the bottom left panel on there
our scorecard results for the EBS which
are negative for the self-renewal
markers and positive for all three tri
lineage markers as expected the
scorecard assay analyzes a number of
genes on and one of the outputs is an
algorithm score which is shown in the
plot on the right the takeaway here is
that undifferentiated pscs cultured in
the two media has very similar algorithm
scores and the same is true of the EBS
for both media this implies that
comparable this implies comparable of
performance in terms of self-renewal
capability for the undifferentiated
cells and Charlie huge potential for the
II B's
so the protocol for transitioning your
PFC is the CTA is very simple you can
take your frozen PSCs that you've
previously cultured in research you see
eight and then just follow them directly
into CTS d 8 or alternately you can take
the cells take cells that you're
currently growing and research you see
eight and then passage them and just
recover them in CTS d8
so as we've seen a few slides
comparing re other research youths and
CTS d8 you can expect a very seamless
transition when you're making the switch
between these two media
you
next I'd like to share some data showing
that PSD properties are maintained in
long term culture using CTS e8 the ICC
image is shown here on this slide show
maintenance of pluripotency markers ox4
SS CA for try one 260 and Sox 2 and this
is after 30 versed in comp passages in
the CTS formulation
here we show that PSC's cultured
long-term maintain the ability to
spontaneously differentiate into all
three lineages
we culture the pfcs for 20 passages in
CTF c8 then generated EBS and essential
six through them as suspension for four
days and then plated them down and allow
them to spontaneously differentiate for
21 days
so the ICC images here shows staining
for three lineage specific markers and
this demonstrates that PSC's cultures
long-term in CGS EA maintain this
Charlie names differentiation potential
you
here on this slide we showed further
evidence that the PFCs are able to
differentiate into three lineages after
long term culture and cts-v ate this
time with directed differentiation using
some of our gift code differentiation
kits
from left to right here we have ICC
staining for markers of definitive to
ended erm cardiomyocytes neuro stem
cells and dopaminergic neural progenitor
and lastly a common concern for stem
cell researchers is maintenance of
normal karyotype in long-term culture
here we showed normal karyotype for PSC
is cultured for 20 versing clump
passages in CT fe8 the left panel shows
normal karyotype by G banding and the
right panel shows the results of curious
stat analysis so a little about curious
stat it's an array based assays that
allows for digital visualization of
chromosomal aberrations and it has a
resolution that is similar to G banding
this curious fat pot has chromosome
number along the x axis and then copy
number on the y axis so when you when
your pscs have chromosome gains or
losses there's a spike in the blue probe
signal that would project above or below
the normal copy number range
however as this plot shows after 20
passages of CTS e8 we did not detect any
chromosomal aberrations via this period
status a
so the take way that I'd like to leave
you is here is that you can have
confidence when you culture PFCs long
term and cts c8 they'll be ready when
you're ready for your downstream cell
therapy applications
so in the next section we'll go through
a workflow for scaling up PS CS and CTS
da
in this workflow pfcs were cultured on
non plastics with increasing surface
area we started with a 60 centimeter
square dish and scaled all the way up to
a to stack milk cell factory system
which is actually a 20-fold increase in
surface area
for this expansion we recommend GPS
connection for your matrix and then see
PS triple select for packaging so using
this combination of CTS EA and non
plastics we were able to scale up to 370
million PS PS per two stack while also
maintaining normal morphology and
pluripotency
so in this final section we'll look at
reprogramming a fibroblast using CT SCA
this first slide shows a completely a-z
no free workflow for reprogramming
fiberglass
using the CTS Saida tune reprogramming
kit in the first part of the protocol
cells are plated and then transduced in
a Zeno free medium on a collagen matrix
the components for the Zeno free media
are shown in the blue box and if you're
interested in the exact recipe it's
available on our website and the user
guide for the CTS site attune kit so
it's a seven the cells are harvested and
replated on either vit Renekton or
laminate 521 and the day after the
medium is switched to CTF v8 and after
the switch emerging emerging at PSC
colonies are seen by day twelve and are
ready for transfer within three to four
weeks
our internal differentiation team
developed the Xena free media that was
described on the previous slide and they
did this by screening a number of media
candidates are then choosing the
formulation that best supported
transduction efficiency fibroblast
growth rate as well as reprogramming
efficiency
they found that the sino free medium
also supports growth of primary
fibroblasts that are eyes that they
isolated from skin punch biopsy they use
this medium to culture expand human
fibroblasts from two to three skin
pieces and the resulting fibroblasts
were found to have normal karyotype
the experiments shown here by robots to
reprogram using the cts sight attune kit
if you remember from the workflow slide
there is a media switch on day 8 to PSC
medium in this case medium was switched
to either research youths
or cts 8 for comparison purposes 18 days
after transduction reprogramming
efficiency which mess was measured by
staining the colonies with alkaline
phosphatase
and as you can see from the plot we're
programming efficiency is comparable for
both media
you
the team was also was able to derive
several new IPs see clones using the CPS
attitude kit with a CTS essentially in
the next few slides I'll show how they a
sigh these clones to confirm
pluripotency differentiation potential
and normal karyotype the pleura test
plot here shows the new PI PSC clones
clustered within the red cloud which is
associated with pluripotent cells
the team use scorecard analysis to
confirm that these clothes have the
potential to differentiate into all
three lineages
and then finally the parental fibroblast
and the new IPs see clones were found to
have a normal karyotype by both
cheondung and bicurious
so in summary we've shown that the
transition from research used to CTS d8
is easy and seamless and you can expect
comparability in terms of morphology
growth kinetics clear potency and tri
lineage differentiation potential
also PSCs cultured long-term and CTS c8
mean take maintain characteristics of
healthy pscs
Eldo PFC expansion can be achieved by
coupling cts CA with the nug cell
factory system
and finally cts-v a medium can be used
to reprogram fibroblast in a completely
Zeno free workflow